ta sébastien huyghe un merci madame la
présidente mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
mais je voudrais dire monsieur le
premier ministre qu'en matière de
sécurité que vous pouvez essayer de
remettre en cause de quinquennat
précédent
il ya une chose de sûre un fait c'est
que la délinquance diminue et résolument
sous le quinquennat nicolas sarkozy et
que depuis françois hollande et
président de la république elle repart à
la hausse
mais ma question n'est pas là monsieur
le président monsieur le premier
ministre à redon demain france
télévisions a choisi de faire de marine
le pen
l'invité vedette de son émission
politique des paroles et des actes
plus de deux heures de direct devant 3
millions de téléspectateurs en moyenne
mais la fille de jean-marie le pen n'est
pas seulement la présidente du front
national elle est aussi la tête de liste
aux élections régionales de la nouvelle
grande région nord pas de calais
picardie
or cette invitation intervient deux
jours avant que ne court le délai de six
semaines qu'ils imposent à france
télévisions l'équité de traitement entre
les candidats
cet avis d'action et donc une rupture
claire des engagements de service public
de france télévisions
devant ce scandale sans pareil delphine
ernotte
la présidente du groupe france
télévisions a été saisie par xavier
bertrand
pas de réponse la ministre de la culture
tutelle de france télévisions a été
saisie par xavier bertrand
pas de réponse c'est la raison pour
laquelle je m'adresse à vous monsieur le
premier ministre et non à fleur pellerin
restée muette sur ce dossier devant la
polémique
nous avons eu pour seule réponse une
proposition indécente de la part de la
rédaction de des paroles et des actes
d'un reportage en campagne de 3 à 5
minutes partagé avec la tête de liste
socialiste sur une émission de plus de
deux heures
c'est une honte cette invitation ne
choque pas uniquement dans les rangs de
l'opposition
le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste a lui même reconnu que
c'était parfaitement anormal et il me
semble qu'il s'est fendu d'une lettre
alors ma question est simple monsieur le
premier ministre
france télévisions at elle décidé de
faire la campagne de marine le pen
auquel cas allez vous réintégrer la
redevance payée par chaque français dans
les comptes de campagne de madame le pen
je wanda
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre
monsieur
sébastien oui j'ai bien compris mais
peau des raisons tout à fait admissible
que la campagne des régionales va
s'inviter régulièrement ici dans cet
hémicycle et votre question votre
question est tout à fait légitime
il y a à conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel qui doit être saisie pour
faire respecter précisément l'équité
entre les candidats aux différentes
élections régionales je crois que nous
pouvons tous nous mettre d'accord là
dessus
ce n'est pas la première fois que ce
type de problème arrive il y aura je
n'en doute pas un seul instant et je
l'espère des débats pour permettre aux
différents candidats dans la région de
faire valoir
bilan et projets il faut le souhaiter
pour la démocratie
en même temps il faut débattre et le
choix du gouvernement et la majorité
c'est débattre c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous faisons un autre choix que
le vôtre et stéphane le foll membre du
gouvernement porte parole sera demain
dans ce débat
dans cette confrontation parce que au
delà de cette question encore une fois
légitime ce qui nous apporte
et ce qui m'importe c'est le débat et
c'est le débat notamment avec et contre
l'extrême droite en france et en europe
sur le fond et sur les idées car le
choix plus que jamais dans notre pays
c'est entre une certaine vision de la
france qui privilégie les valeurs de la
république
le rassemblement l'apaisement la non
l'exploitation des peurs sur le défi
terroristes le défi des réfugiés les
problèmes de sécurité et une autre
vision qui est celle de la rupture et la
volonté au fond de mettre à bas
et le modèle social est certaine vision
de la france
alors plutôt que de parler de la forme
moi monsieur 8 je souhaite que nous
parlions du fonds des projets pour la
france
des projets pour les régions et les
valeurs
et les valeurs à force de courir en paca
ou dans le nord pas de calais de
picardie
derrière les thèses du front national
c'est vous qui fait le jeu de l'extrême
droite alors que plus que jamais nous
avons besoin de nous rassembler autour
des valeurs de la république
la parole est à m